Every great anime needs a supreme evil organization
for the hero to defeat by the end of the story.
And in One Piece, that big bad guy is the
ENTIRE World Government and Marine system.
Which let me tell you this complex system
is SO MASSIVE with TONS of important characters
that it is sometimes incredibly difficult
to know if they are the final boss or a group
that we should be cheering for.
So I’m going to explain how the entire organization
works and it all begins with the surprising
fact that the Marines as a whole are actually
not all that bad.
Because one thing to keep in mind about this
group is that it is ABSOLUTELY ENORMOUS.
And while we don’t have official numbers
there are most likely hundreds of thousands
of marines who work hard to keep the peace
all around the world.
Because despite all of the legendary clashes
we see in the main story, the marine's primary
role is to protect the one hundred and seventy
island kingdoms that are a part of the world
government.
These kingdoms all pay a heavenly tribute
to the world nobles to keep the protection
of the marines.
Plus they kinda get to vote on some things,
which we’ll discuss more about later on.
But the Marines are actually incredibly necessary
for the normal people of the world because
if you live on some random island in the ocean
you probably don’t have many strong fighters
to protect yourselves, so having the Marines
around to fight off evil pirates is 100% a
good thing overall.
Which makes it incredibly ironic that we mostly
view the Marines as bad guys because our main
character Luffy fights against them.
However, we have to keep in mind that Luffy
is a pirate, and it is the marine's job to
protect the world from pirates.
I mean just think about it for a minute.
Almost everywhere he goes he gets into GIGANTIC
FIGHTS that leave a HUGE mess for the island
to clean up.
So if you are just a regular citizen or marine
and you don’t know the true reasons why
Luffy was fighting then you’d probably think
he was a bad guy as well.
So that’s the basic job of the Marines.
Protect people from pirates.
And this is true basically everywhere except
for in the Grand Line, where many islands
are mostly ruled by pirates which we’ll
talk more about that a bit later on.
But how does the system actually work?
Well, to explain, let's work our way up through
the marine ranks.
So imagine you are a good-hearted person who
just wants to help make the world a better
place, kinda like Koby here.
To sign up you probably go to your local marine
base, which are scattered all across the oceans.
Unless you are already a well-known and super
powerful individual, you will more than likely
be starting out at the very bottom rank as
a chore boy.
Which means you’ll probably be spending
a good amount of time on a random marine base
or ship just helping out with the chores.
Then after some time if you show some fighting
abilities you might be promoted to Seaman
Recruit, which means that you are now a common
soldier in the Marines.
So instead of doing chores at a base or ship,
you are now thrown onto the front lines to
defend the people in your territory.
Let’s just hope you don’t get one shot
by literally anyone strong.
Now this is each marine’s basic job all
the way up through the Seaman Apprentice,
Seaman First Class, and even into the different
Petty and Warrant Officer ranks.
But as you move up you’ll probably get more
responsibilities such as communicating orders
to lower rank soldiers and hopefully, there
are some benefits as well.
In fact, the first time that we meet this
black-haired swords woman - who surprising
looks like Zoro’s childhood friend - she
is a Master Chief Petty Officer who works
directly under a marine Captain, which makes
her second-in-command of the entire marine
base at Loguetown.
So just like Tashigi here, you can have a
ton of responsibility even before you become
a Captain.
At least in the four Blue Seas, where the
Marines are typically lower ranked until they
are promoted to the Grand Line.
Although maybe it’s a good thing to stay
around here because as we will see in just
a moment, the higher you rise, the more corrupt
the organization becomes.
But let’s now jump into the actual commissioned
officers starting with Ensign.
Now we are going to stick with Tashigi for
this rank because when we saw her during the
Post-Enies Lobby arc, she had recently obtained
this rank.
Which to be fair I’m not sure how much more
authority this gave her, but I’d assume
that she can give orders to a larger group
of marines and they likely have a certain
area of the sea to patrol.
Plus she is in the Grand Line now, so the
average pirate she will fight is WAY STRONGER.
And that’s clearly what we see her doing
because it looks like she and her allies just
finished protecting an island from a group
of pirates.
But that still doesn’t mean that she has
much freedom to make her own choices in the
Marines.
So if you want to actually have any independence,
how high do you need to go?
Well, let’s skip ahead to the rank of Captain
and see how great having some independence
turns out because it is at this rank that
many Captains get to control their very own
Marine base.
Which can be an ABSOLUTE DISASTER for the
people living around the base.
For example, the very first Captain we meet
in the story is this ax-handed captain of
the 153rd Marine branch, but this dude was
literally evil.
He would heavily tax the villagers, execute
people for talking back to his son, and build
giant statues of himself just to satisfy his
pride.
And if you’re thinking that’s just one
random example of a corrupt Captain, well
there’s also this cat-faced captain who
was SUPPOSED to help free Nami’s village
from this evil Fishmen crew, but he instead
accepted a bribe and stole all of Nami’s
hard earned money instead.
Wow, these guys are just plain awful, which
might make you wonder how they even got their
ranks in the first place.
Well, as we’ll see later on the only thing
that really matters to marines is your fighting
strength.
So as long as you can prove yourself in combat
you will probably keep rising through the
marine ranks.
Which is a stupidly messed up system.
But Captains can also be out on patrol.
And in the Grand Line the rank of Captain
is basically the lowest rank marine who can
put up a decent fight against important pirates.
Everyone else gets completely washed.
Which brings us to Commodores, which is the
rank just below the all-important admiral-type
ranks.
Normally these marines are just higher-ranking
Captains who have similar duties, but there
are a few notable Commodores who deal with
special matters that are too important for
lower rank marines.
For example, this Commodore is in charge of
assigning bounties to pirates all across the
world.
However, they still lack the freedom of higher
ranking marines, as we saw when this chain-smoking
Marine was a Commodore and he complained that
he still needed a higher rank to accomplish
his goal of chasing the straw hats into the
New World.
But now we are getting to a whole new tier
of marines with the rank of Rear Admiral.
At this rank, we are well past your common
marines because these characters are fighters
who can be trusted to hold their own against
strong pirates.
For example, this ruthless lady marine is
now a Rear Admiral as is this clay-using marine
that we recently met in the manga, who has
command of one of the most important marine
bases that is located right next to many of
the Yonko territories.
However, even these strong Rear Admirals ARE
NOTHING COMPARED to the next rank which is
of course the Vice-Admirals.
Not only is this the rank with the most current
known members, but they are essentially the
group of marines trusted with special missions
such as when this guy was sent to bring the
Pirate Empress to Marineford and they were
the largest group of strong marines during
the war at Marineford.
Vice-Admirals are also in charge of massive
fleets of marine battleships, which we see
put to devastating effect when five Vice-Admirals
are sent on a Buster Call like at Enies Lobby.
Vice-Admirals are the first rank to actually
have some degree of flexibility.
For example, when this smoking dude finally
achieves this rank, he can finally fulfill
his wish of chasing after the straw hats.
Then of course there is the hero of the Marines,
Garp, who basically does whatever he wants
as a Vice-Admiral.
Although we do see him following orders from
time to time such as when he escorted the
Fishmen royalty to the meeting of the world’s
rulers.
Interestingly, Vice-Admirals are confirmed
to be excellent fighters.
Many of them have devil fruits, but it is
also officially confirmed that they all know
some form of haki.
But with all that being said, there are galaxies
of difference between the Vice-Admirals and
the next rank.
Which is of course the Admiral tier, which
you can take a shortcut to by subscribing
to the channel for more One Piece content
just like this.
Seriously though, the admirals are commonly
referred to as the Greatest Powers in the
Marines, and for good reason.
To be promoted to the rank of admiral means
that you are one of the strongest fighters
in the entire world.
In fact, there are only ever three of these
positions at one time, and we’ve seen throughout
the story that these marines are devastatingly
powerful in a fight and possess some of the
most broken devil fruits.
Admirals like the light fruit user Kizaru
have nearly killed Luffy multiple times and
even the former admiral Aokiji easily defeated
Luffy.
So these dudes are not people you should mess
around with.
They do have a ton of responsibility though,
as they are essentially the bodyguards of
the world nobles, who we’ll talk about in
just a moment, and whenever there is a Yonko
level threat, the admirals are the ones who
are sent in to deal with the problem.
Each admiral also has their own personal style
of Justice, which influences the actions that
they take.
For example, Aokiji’s justice is Lazy Justice,
which means that he will sometimes follow
orders and other times do what he thinks is
best.
And we saw this when he let Robin escape from
the destruction of her home island.
But there is one even higher rank in the Marines
and that is the position of Fleet Admiral.
Which if I’m being honest, I would not want
this job at all, because even the super aggressive
magma fruit using Akainu went from being a
one-man army as an admiral to being a pencil-pushing
administrator ever since he got this fleet
admiral job during the time skip.
Although he does get to set the main philosophy
of the marines, which in this case means that
the marines now follow Akainu’s Absolute
Justice.
This change in philosophy means that now the
entire marine organization is much more cutthroat
and willing to do whatever it takes to kill
pirates, even if that requires doing some
evil things along the way.
And altogether that is the main structure
of the marines.
But you might be surprised to know that they
are just one single pillar of what makes up
the entire World Government military forces.
That’s because there are actually two other
super important branches of the military that
affect the world in different ways.
The first is the legendary Cipher Pol organization,
whose main jobs involve investigations, spying,
and assassinations.
There are currently six known Cipher Pol groups.
The most known of these groups is CP9, who
were the Straw Hat’s main enemies during
the Water 7 and Enies Lobby arcs.
This particular group specialized in assassinations,
but they were also secret agents who spent
YEARS working undercover to find the blueprints
to the ancient weapon Pluton.
That’s not even the strongest group though
because after the time skip we were introduced
to CP0, which if I’m being honest is essentially
made up of most of the old CP9 agents.
What’s special about this group is that
they work directly for the world nobles, which
if you know anything about those scumbags
then you should know they are up to no good.
In fact, we’ve even seen some of the shadiest
dealings of the world government involving
CP0 such as when they were negotiating with
the evil Shogun of Wano and the Emperor Kaido
to buy weapons and when they were purchasing
orphans from this old lady to train them to
become government agents.
So clearly this branch of the world government
has much more to do with the corruption of
the entire system than any other group we’ve
talked about before.
That’s not even the worst part though because
the other main pillar of the World Government
forces is the entire Warlord system.
And let me tell you this system was completely
messed up from the start.
If you don’t know, the way it works is that
the World Government invites certain pirates
to work for them.
And once a pirate becomes a Warlord, they
basically get to do whatever they want without
any consequences from the Marines.
For example, the Warlords Crocodile and Doflamingo
essentially took over entire kingdoms, but
the marines were restricted from doing anything
to stop them.
However, in exchange for this freedom, the
Warlords must fight for the world government
whenever they are called.
And we really only saw this happen during
the war at Marineford, where the Warlords
helped the Marines fight against the Emperor
Whitebeard.
And this is the perfect time to mention that
the Marines, Warlords, and Yonko make up what
is called the Three Powers of the One Piece
World.
This idea is that the combined strength of
the Marines and Warlords helps balance out
the power of the Yonko.
And with this balance, the strongest pirates
usually stay in their territories in the Grand
Line which keeps the world from being thrown
into chaos.
Which worked out pretty well until the Warlord
system was thrown in the garbage because of
the awful things that some of the Warlords
did.
But that system was quickly replaced by the
new Special Science Group which is made up
of some of the MOST INSANE technology the
world has ever seen.
That’s because the Genius scientist of the
world government has invented an entire army
of super strong cyborgs who can shoot laser
beams plus there are these ultra-powerful
clones that have devil fruit powers and basically
cannot be destroyed.
And with all this incredibly destructive technology,
the World Government is a bigger threat than
ever before.
Oh, and there’s one more special group of
the Marines I haven’t mentioned yet.
This group is called Sword and they are marines
who have officially given up their marine
status, but who still work towards the overall
good of the marine organization.
The only difference is that they are not restricted
by marine orders.
But that unfortunately means that a Sword
member will not be saved by the marines if
they get into trouble.
This was perfectly shown by this Sword member,
who went undercover as a pirate, joined an
Emperor’s crew, but then turned against
Kaido when the straw hats came to defeat the
Emperor during Wano.
And EVERY SINGLE group that I just mentioned
is directly under the control of this guy
who is the Commander in Chief of the World
Government.
Which means that he can basically give orders
to anyone who works for the World Government.
But his main role is to act as a go-between
for the military forces and the world nobles.
And CAN YOU EVEN IMAGINE the insane amount
of ridiculous requests he gets from the World
Nobles?
Because if the entire group of them are similar
to the ones we have already met, then they
have got to be the most selfish, idiotic,
spoiled group of individuals on the planet.
Which you may be wondering how it is even
possible that these people came to be in charge
in the first place.
Well, the answer is that these people are
the descendants of the original twenty kingdoms
who founded the world government over 800
years ago.
Since that time the world nobles have lived
up on top of the Red line, where they hold
absolute power over the world.
That includes the freedom to keep slaves,
kidnap, murder, and waste stupid amounts of
money on ridiculous things.
They can also give orders to the Marines and
cipher pol, plus they are protected everywhere
they go.
However, they do seem to have some of their
own laws that they must follow.
And we only know that because recently in
the manga we were introduced to a brand new
group of government soldiers called the Holy
Knights.
And this group seems to be made up of super
strong World Nobles who have the power to
enforce justice among themselves.
Which we can clearly see when they even kill
one of their own for a certain crime.
Which honestly it seemed impossible that something
like this could happen to these untouchable
figures.
But these Holy Knights are not even the highest
ranking World Nobles.
That’s because the main group of nobles
that we always see making decisions are these
five old men right here.
These are the Gorosei, or the Five Elder Stars.
And this is where the corruption of the world
government truly runs deep because this group
uses all the military forces of the world
government to protect their deepest darkest
secrets, which we’ll talk about in just
a moment.
First though we have to ask, just who are
these five old men?
Well, we know that they are World Nobles,
although unlike the rest they don’t wear
those weird space suits.
Plus we only recently learned their names
and their official government duties in the
manga, and we also don’t know how they were
chosen to be part of the Gorosei.
But the MOST IMPORTANT question that is still
unanswered is if they have actually been alive
ever since the World Government was formed
800 years ago.
I mean the way they talk sometimes makes it
seem like they are immortal gods who view
the races of the world as playthings.
But if they were immortal then surely someone
would have noticed if these dudes ever age
since they are sometimes seen meeting with
other people.
However, that is not even the most mysterious
part about them because as we’ve been shown
throughout the story the Gorosei will do ANYTHING
to protect the secrets of the Void Century.
If you don’t know, this time period occurred
between nine and eight hundred years ago,
but all history of it has literally been erased.
There is no mention of anything during this
time.
However there is ONE MAJOR EXCEPTION, and
that is these unbreakable stone writings called
the poneglyphs which actually record the true
history of the Void Century.
Plus they point towards the direction of Laugh
Tale and the One Piece Treasure.
So yeah, these things are a SERIOUS PROBLEM
for the Gorosei, which makes it a little odd
that after eight hundred years they still
haven’t managed to go around and collect
all of these things.
But whatever the true history is, even it
will probably not be as shocking as the ultimate
power of the world government.
By the way, a major spoiler warning here if
you aren’t caught up to at least the start
of the Wano arc, but in chapter 906 of the
manga it was revealed that there is a actually
secret ruler of the World Government named
Imu who can make even the Gorosei bow down
and listen to their orders.
Seriously, this mysterious person has ALL
THE POWER.
If Imu wants a nearby kingdom wiped off the
map.
They do it.
If Imu wants a certain princess of a kingdom
to be kidnapped.
It is done.
They literally have control over EVERYTHING.
So funnily enough, what is supposed to be
a government where 170 kingdoms come together
every four years to vote on important issues
is truthfully controlled by the world nobles
who are just puppets for this mysterious figure
who we still are waiting to learn more about.
You can kind of think about it like a bad
apple, where on the outside it looks pretty
delicious just like most of the marines are
good people, but once you get inside the apple
it turns out to be completely rotten to the
core.
But now that we’ve reached the top of the
World Government structure there are some
other SUPER IMPORTANT details to mention.
The first is that the government also controls
the justice system which includes the justice
island of Enies Lobby, where criminals are
tried in “court” - which is completely
corrupt by the way - before being sent to
the underwater prison Impel Down.
And as you can see during the Impel Down arc,
this is where the worst pirates and criminals
are sent to be tortured until they die.
Also, I mentioned the founding of the World
Government, but it is worth spending a little
more time on because this history is absolutely
going to play a major role in the final saga
of the story.
That’s because from what little we know
there was a major war way back during the
Void Century.
The original twenty kingdoms of the World
Government fought against an unknown group
that was most likely led by the legendary
figure, Joy Boy. which if you’ve been on
the internet at all recently, you probably
know that Luffy has now inherited the title
of Joy Boy, so we simply MUST learn more about
this time period and how the world government
actually gained their power.
I mean if they’ve spent so much time and
effort keeping the information hidden, it
must be something incredibly dark that they
absolutely don’t want the world to know.
Plus, we also recently learned that the One
Piece World used to be WAY MORE technologically
advanced than it is now.
In fact, the world had giant robots, lasers,
cloning technology, possibly space travel,
and way more awesome stuff that the world
is only now starting to relearn how to do.
So there must be some reason why the world
government wanted to send the world back to
basically the stone age when they began their
rule 800 years ago.
On top of that, there are also the secrets
of devil fruits which are also probably tied
to this time period, so I simply cannot wait
for all of these secrets to be revealed to
the world.
But we cannot mention the world government
and marines without also bringing up the main
groups who oppose them.
There are of course pirates like Luffy and
the Yonko who have major influence in the
world, but honestly these groups aren’t
seriously trying to take each other out.
They only sometimes come into major conflicts
like Marineford.
More importantly though is the revolutionary
army led by Luffy’s father, Dragon, whose
sole mission is to take down the corrupt World
Nobles.
Which the specific wording of this is important
because they don’t actually want to destroy
the Marines, just the evil rulers who sit
at the top of it all.
In fact, only recently have they actually
gone head to head against the world government
in a fight.
For most of the story, the revolutionary army
has been focused on convincing kingdoms all
around the world to leave the world government
and join their revolution.
Which is the exact reason that this kingdom
got completely wiped off the map.
And with this weapon capable of destroying
islands in the world government’s hands,
it is going to take a ton of firepower to
eventually defeat them.
But luckily the one piece world has one of
the most impressive power systems in all of
anime with a HUGE variety of powers like Haki,
Devil fruits, Science and even more.
So if you want a complete breakdown of this
INCREDIBLE AND COMPLEX power system, you can
watch this video right here.
Shanks for watching, and I’ll see you in
the next one.